you got dressed up for me I appreciate
it I did I definitely got dressed up for
you I appreciate that you know went with
a little John Woo I really want to start
with congratulations on the movie
million questions um I guess I have to
start with the most important thing up
front I know you're a huge fan of
Matthew vaugh and I know you really
wanted to work with him uh so ultimately
what did it cost you how much did you
pay to work with him on this I think I'm
forever in his debt so I just think it's
an automatic withdrawal that I don't see
every month it's kind of like signing up
for a gym membership sure you know I
can't cancel it and it just takes for me
every month but it was worth to spend
just as the same as a gym membership
yeah the thing about Matthew is he works
with a lot of the same people again and
again and like once you get in you know
what I mean it opens that door um one of
the things that frustrates me about
Matthew is that he's a very talented
writer director and now effing uh
songwriter yeah right you know what I
mean like f him what a flex um but like
I I want to talk to you because not only
did you you did two songs and they're
both really good you did like a bond
type song over the credits and then you
did electric wait I want to make sure I
say it right electric energy with boy J
Boy George so like I know bananas I mean
we I made the movie we shot this during
the pandemic we did and then uh Matthew
went into post and somewhere along that
time I went an Oscar for Westside Story
and he called me up and he was like cool
you want an Oscar so I think we should
do something else with you in the film
or for the film and I was like what do
you have a mind and he was like you want
to sing some songs and I was like that
sounds fun what have you got and he
played me these tunes that he' had been
working on with Lauren Bal and the great
Stewart Price and Gary Barlo and I was
like yeah I'm so in like let's go put me
in a studio and I would do my best and
then along the way Boy George came on to
write additional lyrics for electric
energy and uh now now now Rogers is also
a part of electric energy so it just it
was the gift that kept on giving and
allowed me to work in a different
different way I'd never you know worked
on music for a film before like this
like Westside Story is a son time
musical that's not what this is um and
we had a great time and I got to live my
disco Queen Adele spy dreams it is also
it's a very catchy song come on you know
I mean f himim I'm so frustrated I'm
joking I am frustrated too so I I want
to touch on one of the things about this
film is it's it's a little hard to talk
about because the twists and turns are
like everywhere so for both of you I'm
curious what is it like reading a script
like this for the first time when it
literally could be anything on the next
page oh it that's thrilling to me yeah
it's a a good book I just I think the
the biggest thing for me is how are they
going to pull that off and hoping that
everyone and this is a testament to
Matthew because he he has such a
distinct Vision uh he knows how he's
going to pull it off and he makes sure
everyone is informed about like hey I
know we're going to film this thing
right now but never for forget that we
did this before this is what's going to
happen after and this is what you're
looking at that's also happened within
10 to 15 twists and turns so he when you
have someone at the top who knows
everything that's going on when you read
something like that it's like sounds
great but how are they going to do it
and then you see it and it's better than
what's in your imagination that's always
another great payoff yeah he's a man
with a plan uh I definitely have to
touch on something else that has nothing
to do with this movie which is uh The
Peacemaker opening credits which obvious
the entire planet loves when did you
realize I mean being serious about this
I've seen it recreated like around the
world when did you realize like oh wait
this is these opening credits are like
what is going on and have you been
practicing the dancing for eventually
The Peacemaker season 2 new opening
credits so I didn't do a lot of practice
before the open of the first season so
I'm I'm hitting you know hitting my same
habit uh I could only hope that for the
next season we have a new number
because uh I I could use the practice so
I'm glad everybody liked the first one
and just like as in with Argy I think we
can build a lot of stories around this
yeah so I hope the world loves Argy so
we can do something like this again
dancing or not and maybe you can give me
some moves ah I got you all right like
literally just call me uh I my last
question for you because I'm just about
out of time you see the shooting
schedule you know what's in front of you
what is the day you have circled in
terms of I cannot wait to film this or
oh my God how are we filming
this
I I was just that was the whole calendar
to me yeah for me for me I think uh I
think just day one on set is important
in any project no matter where you fall
into the Rhythm if you're if you fall in
on day 60 of 100 but it's your first day
I think day one says a lot regardless of
when your day one is you're welcomed
into an environment that takes a village
and Matthew runs with a good crew and he
puts good people around him and day one
was awesome so you know the other days
are going to be right
mhm